boom sound good how sweet day 3 4 3 2
welcome to the late night show that's
you cuz we're gonna be
anxious
yeah
what if I send you this was last Monday
morning in her life
thank you where we going hello I'm in a
funny place where I'm just not scared
I'm just not worried about you know I
just weird I could care less what
anybody thinks that I genuinely care
what everybody thinks
you know it's the kind of this really
yin and yang and so I just realized that
so many of you are scared to fail
because your dad's going to make you
feel bad about it and I'm I've empathy
for that that sucks
like or or your or your husband is going
to say I told you so
I'm very fascinated by negative energy
within our ecosystem that is not cut out
a bull you can get rid of your
acquaintances that's a [ __ ] right
but when your mom's the dick face you're
in trouble yeah and and so I've been
trying to have this conversation of who
are you scared to fail in front of and I
got to tell you in one on one's or
meetups where the content has come from
that's the beauty of doing a vlog
content happens in these moments that I
would have never thought of its captured
it resonates I react to the reaction of
the audience and I and I start trying to
force myself to understand it better
awesome so thanks for having me thank
you thank you guys
[Applause]
literally man thank you so I just booked
it like yesterday at 3 p.m.
that's so nice you had to me I had no no
no pointer okay I'm gonna be in New York
I'll gonna be here the next day I just
wanted to go see the office outside if I
could step inside of you amazing and you
answered I really get email map not you
know Matt right away
and he answered me so I gotta be here at
4:00 something you forgot do my flight
gets delayed because I love it the same
day I landed I work I ran I went under
thinking I am John my dogs near but of
the hotel I dropped everything my
friends are there
I grabbed the train from Jersey
yes to here yes I know not read your
report you're amazing
um under stomach I took two trains the
club crazy and how about this but now we
get through this we'll see you a little
bit
what's cookin sister Monday at 7:00 a.m.
I have a pretty hardcore finance meeting
and by the way it's just so black and
white do you know what I mean if you if
you even account that 90% of the energy
forget about the scope forget about
anything else if 90% of the energy is
based on sales conversion digital sales
it's just not it's not it's not I'm not
doing a good job of putting the best
players in the best position to succeed
the good news is and I think you know
this about me like I think what uh what
makes me pretty successful is I ID eight
and I adjust and I'm not willing to I'm
not scared to say okay that's not right
I'm doing this you know I'm not
ideological around my own [ __ ] you'd
never really do know like if the CEO has
a real pulse of entrenches and I think
that's something I do pretty well but I
love about this as it's one click to get
into their push notification but then
it's like - why you think you're
building a good business then you're on
the drink like old email it's so
valuable the attention right now and I
don't have a and I don't want to build
the app to like do the alternative
version to this this is the low cost way
to get the best value of what Apps can
do for most people okay I need to run
everybody knows what to do wow man as
how you been it's great to see it man
the biggest comment I get from people
when they come into this office is how
loosey-goosey and not tense it feels
when people come to my company everybody
likes to talk about you know when I do
this blog everybody's like sometimes
somebody will come in and razz me like
you don't do anything oh no no no I
don't do anything the way you define it
yes I do not go outside and shovel yes
I'm not sitting on my computer in Final
Cut and editing I'm doing the thing that
matters have a great day man I love how
are you so good thank you what's cooking
okay
these sort of is love stories TV and
we're building the first and largest
library of real wedding videos
Oh real what wedding videos people are
hiring a videographer for everything to
do is to hire a photographer for a
hundred noxious weddings its engagements
its proposals its gender reveals its day
of birth its counting its first this is
how every human beings can do everything
about everything everybody's gonna have
a d-roc okay so my life philosophy
except I think eventually be rocks gonna
be like a Pokemon ball you throw it up
in the air and just follows you around
yeah I could drop like yeah but who's
gonna add someone plus it's the energy
it only the editing yeah everybody loves
dirac it's Tyler like I kept like for
example I can really tell Wendy rock at
its verses when Tyler and it's like
that's the storytelling and the amazing
content so so I think what we need to do
is you've won on step one go win that
vaynermedia does everything but
everybody but we won social media first
to be the gateway drug to everything got
it yeah you've already won this in
theory now actually win it and the way
you actually win it is be the number one
ecosystem for it okay thank you welcome
have a great day
[Music]
when that's this work like a question
out of curiosity how you get people to
be honest with you as in you Gary B and
like who's gonna say like no Gary you're
wrong people say it uh you're you're not
seeing this through when no I think
you're right uh you try to make people
feel safe I'm tough because I'm a good
debater and I'm logical and I'm very
much only talking about my own [ __ ] that
I'm talented in so the reason I don't
like a lot of people like you're
surrounded by yes man I'm like yeah cuz
you only see me talking about my great
skill yeah you know what I mean so it's
a you know yeah exactly what was
somewhat cut development I'd be like
yeah I like PHP you're like no Gary
Ruby here's why I'm like oh you know
yeah so I think that um I think you have
the context which conversations yeah
yeah and it's true they do it so I'll
give a good example yeah a lot of people
come in and try to challenge me cuz they
think a lot of people don't challenge me
and they're gonna bring value and I'm
they're gonna stand out by challenging
me yeah the problem is if they're wrong
and what they're saying they lose yeah
yeah some you know when people need
comments on my show or other news and
they're like this is boring I'm like yes
I'm like yep I'm gonna bore the [ __ ] out
of you guys for the rest of your life
because I just I just don't believe in
that many things I'm not gonna make up a
new pillar right there's interpretations
of those tried and true and addressing
that as such
embodying exactly who you are your
identity who's your identity you own it
to work with it and that's it and that's
what you never waver Cheers just that I
couldn't get my home button to work for
13 seconds this morning I freaked my
[ __ ] I was like dead
that's like seriously didn't catch that
on film er that was before it I would
have been funny the second one was son
man let me sit now my phone my phone oh
would you like no here all yours I think
you forgot that down your it sounds like
that right might be nothing up
yes when you aren't a first mover in
industry like Wine Library TV buzz or on
a social channel like Instagram Facebook
there which all have so many people now
how do you go about breaking through the
noise to how it you know why I'm except
you know why mix you know you know what
I'm excited I'm excited because I have a
lot of respect for this room there's a
lot of talent in this room just because
you weren't first doesn't mean you can't
be best like now remember best comes in
two fold that's why I made that point if
you're actually great at what you do for
a living that's only part of it you have
to be great at communicating it in the
way it's communicated today like you
have to you have to understand angles
and pictures or what works in video or
how to use hashtags to be discovered
when nobody knows who you are they both
matter but shouldn't you put in the work
if you get the benefit you know what I
mean we are strong as [ __ ] we're really
[ __ ] strong we're just being sold
that we're not because there's a lot of
money a lot of money and telling us that
we're not pretty enough thin enough
smart enough good enough [ __ ] that I
want to tell you you're the [ __ ] best
go do [ __ ]
[Applause]
I don't think you can hire nothing about
that
I was actually do [ __ ] I don't really
think that you can see back anything is
possible we can be a stop
stop watching me
you say we're not the same weights oh my
god I'm my foot everybody know I know
yeah OCD the guy that I see today
a lot of this training down why don't
get me started
I can't wait Raleigh girls wanna give my
love telling that you can see I know
girl anything is possible
stop your phone
got it but I think in the short term the
big thing that I want to make sure is
I'm not creating any vulnerabilities for
17 scopes and the momentum I'm creating
with like just want to make sure when I
think of today I think of it as in three
parts I guess not being or remember like
without you know obviously I think a lot
about the things that have bubbled up
from emails that I've gotten from like
hey when I sent you so there's that and
I feel like that's bubbling up again so
I want to get some clarity creative and
strategy and paid media then macro
issues like I'm a really intense next
four or five days
you know we specifically I made it such
a monumental belt bed on and very
honestly it's created a little bit of a
financial pickle for me that I'm dealing
with it I'm spending a lot of time on
personally right now and it's crippled
me in this short term but I'm pumped
because I think the long term really
plays out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when we're coming in and saying now in
2017 is look you're gonna make a big one
or two so instead of taking four four
videos and making twenty nine do four
three videos but do four five seven nine
videos over here
the thing that brands aren't doing well
is they're not getting themselves enough
chances to win that's it five years ago
you guys were right
it's that Facebook has the actual
distribution reach
I gotta go see my way home guys I'm fine
I'm gonna get you do time to go for my
wife's gonna kill me is that how you
first saw me yeah that's like one of my
favorite uh you know what by the way
somebody look it up right now tell me
the date we're doing an anniversary
edition Google beer look at old Google
you search every year yeah
love you guys
I really want I really wanted to all
right dear I come out of here
just watch the nostalgia on Friday night
and now Maddie the way you're gonna make
money while the big boys are maybe out
of your league or you're not ready to
give a PowerPoint presentation and wear
a tie and go to Madison Avenue don't
when you're gonna make money is by
grabbing it
[Music]